ah
give me a second sure oh my god
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by anthony mackie
you know him from films like the hurt
locker captain america million dollar
baby and many more
his latest film outside the wire is
currently trending on netflix and he
also stars in one of the year's most
anticipated new shows
the falcon and the winter soldier which
is set to release on disney plus march
19th
anthony mackey welcome to the show
what's up man thank you for having me
i know that you grew up near the bayou
how do you handle this spicy stuff
i don't do well with spicy stuff at all
anybody will tell you i like my food as
bland as possible
[Music]
all right
it's not bad it's kind of like ketchup
i can live with that
[Music]
so i want to start by talking about
falcon and the winter soldier and
specifically this quote of yours from
2014 where you said
the second and third leads are always
the best characters
what did you mean by that and what do
you see as the opportunity to
build or redefine the character of
falcon in this series
well the lead character is usually
someone just to help
push the exposition along push the story
along
he's the one that you ride with
throughout the vehicle the best
characters
are always the third fourth lead because
they're the ones who actually get it to
get in and do the dirty work they're the
ones that get to act
so they're always the ones bouncing
and controlling the lead actor and he's
just bringing them along for the ride
that's why when you watch the academy
awards best supporting actor is always a
more
coveted category than best actor
so with six hours of content you really
get the opportunity to delve into not
only
the falcons backstory but the winter
soldier's backstory
like if you see with juan division after
watching that show you have a much
richer
and deeper relationship with vision and
wanda
now and whereas before you know you
would i would
maybe have one maybe two nuggets per
movie
and but the movie was focused on the
heavy hitters the ironmans the captain
america so
you know now i get more i get more play
time so you get to learn more about me
no that's actually good so new orleans
has a lot of nicknames the big easy
paris of the south but as an avid
fisherman my guess
is the one that rings truest to you is
the sportsman's paradise
when you think about all the fish that
you've had to fight
on the hook is there one that you would
consider a prized catch
oh definitely great question no one has
ever asked me this before
okay so while we were shooting in game
and infinity war they had these huge
lakes and ponds on their properties
so in between takes i would go fishing i
bought an
outdoor grill for my trailer like fresh
fish
right there on set which some people had
a problem with
until they taste the fish then they
understood my situation
i watch a lot of these river monster
shows that oftentimes feature the
marshes or the swamps of louisiana
what's like the weirdest thing that
you've ever pulled out of the water
actually when we were shooting abraham
lincoln vampire hunter here in new
orleans
and they have these fish called
alligator garfish it's like a pike
but with the face of an alligator so one
day i'm sitting out damn smoking a cigar
i have a pa with me so i don't get in
trouble so the pa is just sitting there
talking to me like oh this is so much
fun i can't believe we're on a movie
all of a sudden the line starts to
stretch out
and there's a garfish about five feet
long
just munching on this fish so i take the
lime
i tie it to the bumper of the truck
pulled the truck
out from the water so it brought the
fish out
it was the biggest garfish i had ever
seen it was bigger than this girl this
girl was like five
two and this fish was like five five so
she freaked out
gets on the radio oh my god we have oh
my god oh my god somebody help us
but it was just the ability to catch it
and hold it so i have a picture
of this garfish like laying across my
chest in full costume
when we were shooting abraham lincoln
vampire hunter
[Music]
hmm i can live with that
so you've amassed 70 plus tv and film
credits over the course of your career
which would speak to an
appetite for exploring a variety of
different characters and genres
do you still to this day get stopped on
the street by law order fans even though
you've only been in one episode
i i always say i'm most famous for eight
mile
in law and order i always know because
you know a lot of people don't watch
marvel movies whenever i go to the
grocery store
and you know all the older ladies know
who i am
i'm like law and order came on because
they didn't watch captain america they
watch them all in order
from who they are i know where they
recognize me from
like you can guess which movie or which
show they recognize you from
what's the difference between an
eight-mile fan and a marvel fan
so a eight mile fan ironically enough is
usually like a
cool hip like middle-aged just
down-to-earth real cool cat
but marvel is usually either a
middle-aged
dude who's very grabby and touchy
or a teenage kid who can't hold their
[ __ ]
like there's no in between it's like you
know
little girls giggle and run away little
boys just stop
and freak out and middle-aged dudes just
always want to touch you and never leave
you alone it's the weirdest [ __ ] ever
it's the weirdest weird
so i know that you're suspicious of
people who take new orleans food and bar
culture and then move them to cities
like over here in new york where they
don't really understand the roots so
if you'll humor me i want to play a
little game called
who dat or not that where i give you a
new orleans culinary export
and you tell me if it has who dat status
or if it's just straight a not that red
flag does that sound good
i like it i like it all right a seafood
joint
that serves year-round crawfish boils
not death not that
not that not that like we're right at
the precipice of crawfish season right
now
so your crawfish is just now coming out
the mud so
if you got crawfish off season
those are imported crawfish i'm not
gonna stay where they from
but you have mud bugs and you have
scuttle butts
those are scuttlebutts a new orleans
themed bar where the bartender doesn't
know how to make milk punch
oh that's hard see i'll give them a pass
on that because milk punch is very
very local very very like in the grind
if you have a new orleans themed bar and
you know how to make a
sazerac i'll forgive you on milk punch
if you have a daiquiri machine
if you serve dixie beer you know abita
if you have a beater
giacomo i'll give you that but milk
punches
i'll give you a pass on that but you got
to have something to replace it
a sandwich shop that serves po boys with
cape cod
chips no po boys should only be eaten
with zaps
that's the only thing and the crawtators
are the best ones
don't tell me the voodoos are the best
ones it's not true it's the crawl
tickets everybody take the crawl tape
let me hit you with this phrase gluten
free king cake
no no
no
oh [ __ ] this is gonna hurt i went too
far
[Music]
you called it you called it
[Music]
oh all right anthony we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
grammar we do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture you
just tell us the bigger story
and we have a little workaround because
your instagram currently has one picture
anthony but we have a workaround
which celebrity all-star game do you
remember more fondly
last summer's softball match or the nba
all-star game from three years ago
first of all i had a great
great showing in cleveland
at the all-star game for mlb i had three
catches
inside the park home run never struck
out should have won the mvp i scored
more runs than anybody
but we're not going to talk about it i
got to hang out with the big hurt it was
amazing i grew up loving baseball
the basketball all-star weekend it was
all about master p
and he took like 35 three-pointers and
missed all of them
i'm like what are we doing right like
why are we oh we're just out here for
cardio
yeah so it was the the
the parties were better at all-star
weekend for basketball
i had a better experience with mlb
hanging out with ryan howard hitting
home runs crushing it
this looks like you're reigning here as
the king of bacchus
bacchus is one of the super parades and
bacchus is known as the workmen's
parade carpenters uh contractors
mechanics like they're all members of
bacchus because you don't have to be
rich to be a member
it started as a society of guys who work
together
as a crew my dad would take us down to
the beginning of bacchus on napoleon and
chapatulis
and you have the knights the horsemen
that ride before the parade
in their full costumes on horseback
southern university's marching band was
right there so we got to ride
like with like around in southern's
marching band you know so we used to do
that every year and it was always
an amazing amazing experience for
for mardi gras to be able to do that and
you know new orleans has such unique
culture and aesthetic
they try to capture it in tv and film
all the time even artists like
drake or beyonce can you think of a tv
show
a film a music video that you think best
distills new orleans there's this movie
called angel heart it came out like in
the
early 80s late 90s a creepy movie with
uh lisa
lisa uh lisa bonet it captures
new orleans culture and essence it was
so new orleans it was creepy
one of my favorite movies every time i
watch it it freaks me out but i feel
like it captures
new orleans better than anything
[Music]
oh all right there we go
[Music]
that's gangster
heavy flavor oh my god
so with 22 movies under its belt now
this collection of marvel series headed
to disney plus the mcu
it's ever expanding what do you see as
the unique
challenges of remaining true to these
classic
superhero stories while also then
building and creating new stories
well the problem is you know
you every movie has to be bigger than
the one before
so every movie has to be more outrageous
more extreme
so i find it hard to capture
the reality of the story or stay true to
the comic book
so it's i don't think the problem is the
characters or the story
i think it's just how do you evolve
these movies to where
you don't see the same thing over and
over i always laugh because marvel loves
to show
like six suvs in a row going down the
highway
like every movie you know every movie
has the six suv
like uh like convoy you know going
somewhere so it's like how do you
take that six suv convoy and make it new
and different
every single movie i think that's the
biggest challenge
so this is the honey badger new orleans
finest right there
oh yeah
[Music]
ah it doesn't help that it has killer on
it
so some people watching this may be
surprised to learn that you're actually
a very skilled carpenter
is it still a dream of yours to do a
home improvement show
it is it um i
literally you still watch
i used to watch hd i used to wat now my
tongue is like
i used to watch hgtv all the time still
and i've always wanted to do like a
cooking show
and a home improvement show and a
wellness show and put them all together
just
hdtv espn and food network
that's all i watch yeah but i would love
to do one that would be
fun as hell can you describe in detail
the last piece of furniture that you
built
so over covet
i've been working in my backyard and um
got some 2x4 metal studs cut them out
party board
and tiled and built a outdoor kitchen
my brother-in-law was telling me about
epoxy you pour it in
and it hardens like glass but you can
put objects in it
and it'll float around the objects i
want to figure out how to do epoxy
countertops and you can put lights under
them
maybe some real pimp [ __ ]
i'm sorry all of us out the window now i
can't breathe
[Music]
oh it just looks like mud dude
what eat that
still going in though
oh my gosh oh
[Music]
ah give me a second sure holy [ __ ]
oh my god i'm coming
oh my god i know i know be careful
around the eyes too this is the part
where i'll say be careful around the
eyes you don't want right
across pollination issue right all right
i figured this out
what do you got going over there i
should have had bread
but i didn't get bread so i figured corn
chips would be the closest thing
that's a new one to me how does it work
out
corn chips dog corn chips dog i'm back
anthony mackie pro tip all right i have
a million questions about eight mile but
i'll keep them to my most pressing here
so that we can move on down the gauntlet
i know we're probably on borrowed time i
guess
overall the thing that i'm most curious
about are the battle rap
scenes are there juilliard techniques to
draw on when it comes to ripping a mic
on camera uh you know what's interesting
i find
myself very lucky to have studied
shakespeare
um
when you look at shakespeare the way he
wrote he wrote in verse
so the idea of approaching a rapper from
the perspective of an actor
you're really just speaking in poems you
know i've always said one of the
greatest
rappers to ever live was william
shakespeare so
it helped a lot as far as
being able to understand the cadence
the verse the meter and putting those
words in rhyming couplets
and into form
i can't believe i got that out
oh [ __ ] okay
go ahead okay cool i'm i've got i'm i'm
running i'm running now i'm running
so these days you're one of the most
recognizable film stars on the planet
but i know that the foundation was set
at
juilliard which is widely regarded as
one of the most prestigious drama
schools in the world
some trade schools are mandatory and
then there are others that are almost
looked down on like journalism for
example there are a lot of people who
think
you're better off learning on the job
than going to journalism school
where does drama school fall on that
spectrum for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
um the uh
there's nothing more import i've learned
a lot
um being on set uh in the business
there's nothing more important to me
than
the training i got in drama school i'm a
firm believer and
to be is to study you would not go to a
hospital and let somebody cut on you who
didn't go to medical school
you know if i didn't have my training i
wouldn't be able to play tupac
martin luther king papa doc and the
falcon
i would only be able to play tupac at
every movie i would only be able to play
martin luther king in every movie or the
falcon in every movie i wouldn't be able
to do those different range of
characters
so that training is just something that
gives you an extra leg to stand on
you know what i mean so once you have
that background in that training
nobody can take that from you
dude that that hurt one more
it's not fun either
just being honest with you but you know
what anthony some hosts they'd let you
drown all the wings you know they
wouldn't be they wouldn't be telling you
where the minds are
i appreciate it now i'm happy because my
mouth
and my nose and my lips are numb so
i can't feel anything anyway
here we go
[Music]
yo that's just straight peppa facts but
you know what anthony mckee
here we are at the epilogue of our spicy
wing journey and you're an
actor who's seen tremendous success with
some of the biggest box office smashes
of all time
as well as admiration for your work on
broadway so with that in mind i want to
take things back
to this 2010 quote that you gave to the
juilliard journal
i'd like to show everybody that not only
can i do something like the hurt locker
or notorious
i can also do shakespeare is there a
shakespearean
soliloquy or a side that comes to mind
when you think about your dinner date
this evening with the wings of death
oh my god
thou nature art my goddess
to thy law my services are bound
wherefore should i stand in the plague
of custom and permit
off i can't
it's a standing ovation from this side
of this
that was amazing and look at you anthony
mackie
taking on the wings of death and coming
through victorious
couple laps little sweat but it's all in
a day's work
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you
this camera probably just the camera
you're looking at let the people know
what you have going on in your life
oh man synchronic is coming out
movie theater let's go check it out go
to the drive-in snuggle up close
streaming it's a really fun movie
outside the wires on netflix check it
out
number one in the world and in march
we have falcon winter soldier to be a
good time
check it out
oh great job anthony great job
problem was it started off
so nice and easy i thought it was going
to continue to be nice and easy
oh
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say
thank you so much for watching today's
episode if you enjoyed it
maybe like it maybe you maybe throw us a
subscribe even if you're feeling
generous
and as long as you keep watching [ __ ] it
i'll keep eating